despite the partial reopening of some
black support working on alternative
trade routes to and from Ukraine remains
of crucial importance for the country
for Europe and for the World At Large
especially for food security
on the basis of our work on the ground
over the last months the ebrd intends to
invest 300 million euros over 2020
through 2023 in support to solidarity
Lane reflecting our common priorities
with the commission
investment is needed but not only
streamlining border crossing procedures
is also of critical importance
eprd is already investing or preparing
projects in Ukraine Moldova Poland and
Romania for example we are preparing a
200 million euros loan to the Ukrainian
Railways that will be partly dedicated
to address border crossing bottlenecks
and improve connectivity with the EU in
Moldova we've just provided 100 million
euros to extend the world Network
towards the Ukrainian border and in
Poland we've just supported the
expansion of the Diane sport on the
Baltic Sea
we are considering additional urgent
investment in these four countries in
key ports and Railway infrastructures as
well as for Ukrainian Silo capacity
expansion
together with the commission we will
gather all public and private
stakeholders in the coming weeks so as
to coordinate all efforts and we
continue to work actively with other
financial institute
Institute at the time where the brave
Ukrainian people are fighting the least
we can do is to deliver as soon as
possible on these projects you can count
on dvrd's Resolute commitment thank you